[Music]
it is the best-selling book in history
no volume ever written has been more
loved and quoted and its words sometimes
simple and sometimes mysterious should
always be studied carefully it is the
Bible the Word of God welcome to Bible
answers live providing accurate and
practical answers to all your Bible
questions this broadcast is a previously
recorded episode to receive any of the
Bible resources mentioned in this
broadcast call 885 6 7 4 7
once again that's 800 eight three five
six seven four seven now here's your
host from amazing facts international
Pastor Jean Ross hello franz liszt his
past as Jean Ross past the Doug is out
this evening but how about an amazing
fact the honeyguide a bird about the
size of a Robin that lives in East
Africa eats all kinds of insects but it
is especially fond of honeybee grubs but
getting them is not so easy the wild
bees of Africa are dangerous and they
live in secluded areas although the
honey guide has a way of finding them it
does not dare to enter the hive unaided
even if it could drive off the bees its
lend a delicate bill could not penetrate
their nests which are usually in hollow
trees or on cliffs so it gets a friend
to help with the task in northern Kenya
for example the men from the Brawn tribe
make money selling honey hi tribesman
goes out into the countryside and claps
his hands whistles in a certain way or
blows across a snail shell if a
honeyguide bird is not far off it will
generally appear very quickly and sing a
special chattering call which it never
otherwise uses when sure that the man's
attention has been caught it flies off
in low swooping flight which is easy to
follow as it flies its tail feathers are
spread wide so that the white outer
feathers are clearly displayed the man
follows whistling and shouting to let
the bird know that he is coming as the
two traveled together
the bird gradually
hands-on lower and lower branches until
it song changes to a low whistle that it
repeats two or three times and then
becomes quiet and it flies over to a
perch where it sits quietly as the man
approaches he can see that the bird is
sitting very close to the entrance of
the bee's nest the man carefully draws
closer and sets a small fire just upwind
from the nest the stupefies the bees and
then he opens the nest and he strikes
the honeycombs he hangs up part of a
honeycomb for the bird the bird flies
over eats the white bee grubs and also
some of the honeycomb Wang's the
honeyguide bird is one of the only
animals that can digest beeswax
now who taught the honey guide to lead
people to the bees nests and who gave it
at the low swooping flight and the white
signal feathers in its tail who told the
bird to be quiet when it comes close to
the nest so the bees will not stand to
death and who gave the bird the ability
to digest beeswax who else stay tuned
for more as amazing facts brings you
this edition of Bible answers live
[Music]
you're listening to Bible answers live
accurate and practical answers to your
Bible questions hello friends welcome
back this is Bible answers live a live
International Bible study and we would
love to hear from you this evening as
nation pass that egg is out of town but
we do have phone lines that are open and
if you have a Bible related question the
number to call is eight hundred four six
three seven two nine seven that'll get
your call here on the studio on studio
phones and get your call on the program
this evening again that's 800 four six
three seven two nine seven and also like
to greet our friends who are joining us
on Facebook on the amazing facts
Facebook page and also the Doug
Batchelor Facebook page and again if you
have a Bible question feel free to give
us a call and we'll try to take your
bible question on tonight's program now
we open the program by talking about a
honeyguide bird which has the strange
way of working with people to lead it to
its honeycomb or to the bees house so
that it can get some honeycomb and of
course we can see many things in nature
that reveal to us a Creator someone who
designed these different animals and
giving them different abilities and also
giving them the ability to work with
other creatures and of course God is the
one that created all things and we have
a free offer that talks about some of
the marvels of creation and how they
prove that intelligent design was needed
for these animals and some of these
things in nature and we'll be happy to
send this to anyone who calls an ask
this is our free offer for tonight's
program it's called amazing wonders of
creation it's one of our sharing books
and all you'll have to do to receive
that is to call the number eight hundred
eight three five six seven four seven
again that number is 885 six seven four
four seven that is our resource phone
line and as for the book amazing wonders
of creation and again if you have a
Bible question the phone line here the
studio is eight hundred four six three
seven two nine seven I say we have a
number of folks
waiting with their Bible question but
before we go to the phone lines let's
start with the word of Prayer dear
father we thank you for the opportunity
that we have this evening to open up
your word and study together we thank
you for the technology that allows us to
have this International Bible study and
Lord as we open up your word we ask for
the Holy Spirit to come and guide us be
with those who are listening wherever
they might be and lead us into a clearer
understanding of what the Bible teaches
for we ask this in Jesus name Amen
well being to go straight to the phone
lines then our first call of the behalf
is Josiah and Josiah welcome to the
program hi just I how old are you eight
years old all right well thank you for
calling
what is your Bible question um if the
devil turned a good wood God let him
back into heaven and forgive him okay
good question Josiah if the devil turns
good will God let him back into heaven
well the Bible tells us that it's the
goodness of God that leads a person to
repentance so in order for a person to
repent and in order for a person to be
forgiven they need to repent we need the
Holy Spirit to guide us but there is a
point where a person can so harden his
or her heart against the Holy Spirit
that the Holy Spirit can no longer
convict them of this sense and the Bible
speaks of that as being the unpardonable
sin or the sin against the Holy Spirit
now in the case of the devil or Satan he
has reached that point where his heart
has gotten so hard that he rejects the
Holy Spirit and there's nothing God can
do to bring him to a point of repentance
if he doesn't repent he can't be
forgiven and of course he can't empty
into heaven so is there a chance that
the devil would repent no he's hardened
his heart he's gone past that point but
the good news is we can still repent and
if we repent of our sins God promises
that he would forgive us and cleanse us
from all unrighteousness so Josiah thank
you for your question this evening you
know we do have a series of studies and
amazing facts called the amazing
adventure lessons and if you've not seen
any of those I'd encourage you to talk
to your parents tell them you'd like to
see the amazing adventure series that
amazing facts has and I think you'll be
blessed thank you for your call next
caller that we have is Duncan calling
from Ontario Canada Duncan welcome to
the program yes good evening a Pastor
Ross I'm a first-time caller from Ottawa
Ontario Canada and I will sit on a
regular basis via Alexa and my question
is in the new heavens and the new earth
in God's new heaven and earth will there
be seasons and I'll take my answer over
the air alright well thanks for your
call Duncan question is in the new
heavens and the new earth that God's
gonna create are they going to be
seasons well one of the things we do
know for sure in Revelation chapter 22
verse 2 that there will be months
because we read in revelation 22 - in
the middle of its street and either side
of the river was the Tree of Life which
bought 12 fruits each tree yielding its
fruit
every month and then it says the leaves
of the tree Oh for the healing of the
nation so we know from every month there
will be a new fruit on the tree of life
it's gonna be 12 months you'd assume in
the year but are they gonna be the
extremes of seasons that we find now I
don't think so at least not to the
extent that we have it here the Bible
doesn't specifically say but a lot of
the problems that we have in the earth
is a result to the extremes of seasons
or whether it be deserts or places that
have too much rain or flooding it often
has to do with certain seasons we do
know that in the earth mainu there will
be no deserts there won't be flooding
there won't be suffering or destruction
in any form so I think the climate is
going to be just perfect and it's gonna
be perfect year-round the new heavens
the new earth that God is making we're a
fact it's gonna be so wonderful that the
Bible says man hasn't even been able to
imagine I have not seen nor ear heard
neither entered into the heart of man
the things that God is preparing for
those that love him so we're not quite
sure what it's going to be like but you
know
it's gonna be good and we want to be
there so again thank you for your call
next caller that we have let's see we've
got Carol listening in Michigan Carol
welcome to the program hi thank you yes
thank you I
tonight was the first night that I've
heard your broadcast okay and I thought
this would be a perfect time to ask this
question can you tell me anything about
somebody speaking in tongues okay
pounded battle Bible and my friend of
mine asked me well what is the
difference between parables and speaking
in tongues and I told her what parables
were you know God actually telling a
story of his ministry and but I couldn't
answer about the speaking thanks okay
good question let me see if I can give
you a few verses on that we do find in
the Bible the gift of tongues as one of
the gifts that God has given the church
but what we need to understand is the
word tongue in the Bible means language
a language is something that is used to
communicate the thought so when we're
talking about a tongue and the gift of
tongues or speaking in an unknown tongue
it's referring to a language being able
to communicate or preach in a language
now the first reference that we have of
this is in Acts chapter 2 and verse 4
this is when the Holy Spirit came upon
the Apostles 120 that were disciples
that were gathered in the upper room we
call it the day of Pentecost and the
Holy Spirit came upon them there was a
large group of people that had gathered
there from different regions in the
Roman Empire they had gathered in
Jerusalem because of the Pentecost and
it says in verse 4 and they were filled
with the Holy Spirit and began to speak
with other tongues as the Spirit gave
them utterance so they began to preach
and teach in languages that they had not
previously known it was a supernatural
gift that God had given them and you're
looking for a 6 it says and when the
sound occurred the multitude came
together they were confused
because everyone heard them speak in his
own language that's verse 6 of Acts
chapter 2 so the purpose of the gift of
tongues was to communicate the gospel to
share the gospel with people so that
they be able to understand the gospel
being able to share the Word of God now
today when we talk about tongues people
think of some kind of utterance in a
language that nobody understands they
don't even understand that well we don't
find any case in in the Bible where
people were speaking in a language or
speaking with different sounds or or
making a noise that was not
understandable
in order for somebody to preach in a
language that the audience did not
understand Paul said in that case you
need to have somebody translate for
those that are there so that's what it
means when it says the Apostles spoke
with different tongues they had the
ability to speak with these languages
that they hadn't previously learned does
that make sense Carl most of it does
part of it part of it I'm confused on
because my other question to you which
is part of this is I had a my best
friend's husband died this was years ago
back in the late 70s and he before he
passed he was in the hospital and his
mother was there and just before they
pronounced him dead she started speaking
in tongues and I couldn't understand
what she was saying it can anybody
understand when somebody speaks in
tongues it was a language I've never
heard right well it needs to be a
language that someone will understand
will hear because the purpose of the
gift of tongues is to communicate the
gospel and as I mention a little earlier
there is a common belief today and there
are many sincere Christians that believe
speaking in tongues or speaking in got
some type of language or
type of I don't know I don't even know
what you'd call it it's just different
words or sound
or mutterings is somehow communicating
something but if no one can understand
it then it's it's not a biblical time
it's not the gift of tongues that we
read about in the Bible that is
something else you know Carol we do have
a book that I'll be happy to send you
it's free all you need to ask for it is
called understanding tongues and it goes
into a lot more detail gives you a lot
more verses and we'll deal with this
question of why is it that in the
religious world there are some who claim
to speak in this tongue what exactly is
that and what if the Bible say to
receive that just call our resource
phone line that's eight hundred eight
three five six seven four seven and ask
for the book called understanding
tongues and we'll be happy to send that
to you
next call of the behalf let's see we
have David listening in New Jersey David
welcome to the program thank you very
much
my question is besides that in a
marriage what are the conditions are
allowed in the Bible to divorce and
remarry okay so the Bible is pretty
clear when it comes to the subject of
divorce
there were people actually asked Jesus
at one point what can you put away your
your spouse and Jesus said well in the
beginning God created them male and
female and he made marriage to be a
permanent commitment between two people
so you know in the case of death of
course somebody is freed from that
commitment that covenant that they've
made but the bible does give one
exception for that and that is in the
case of adultery if somebody commits
adultery that's matthew 19:9
that person then if that brings the
marriage apart the one who is innocent
is able to get a divorce and get
remarried
okay can you quote which chapter in
verses that I can read it sure Matthew
chapter 19 and verse 9 it says whoever
divorces his wife except for sexual
immorality and
he's another commits adultery and
whoever marries her who is divorced
commits adultery matthew 19:9 okay you
know we very much got your welcome you
know we do have a book that we can send
you it's called marriage divorce and
remarriage and it deals with the subject
and gives you a whole lot more Bible
verses I think you'll find it helpful if
you'd like to receive it just call the
number eight hundred eight three five
six seven four seven as for the book on
marriage it's called marriage divorce
and remarriage and we'll send that out
to you
Janice is listening from Florida Janice
welcome to the program
Janice you there doing well and your
Christian this evening alright let me go
ahead and read it so those who are
listening therefore I say unto you every
sin and blasphemy will be forgiven man
but blasphemy against the Spirit will
not be forgiven man anyone who speaks a
word against the Son of man it shall be
forgiven him but whoever speaks against
the Holy Spirit it will not be forgiven
him either in this age or in the age to
come so your question is then what is
the sin that can't be forgiven can be
forgiven but the one of the Holy Spirit
it cannot be okay yes let me see if I
can share a little insight in that the
Bible tells us that it's the goodness of
God that leads us to repentance so it's
the Holy Spirit that brings conviction
of a son and I need of a savior and we
want to respond to that we wouldn't even
have an interest in spiritual things if
it wasn't for the Holy Spirit to kind of
draw us to a realization lead us to a
realization that we need God and we need
salvation the sin against the Holy
Spirit is when someone continually
rejects the prompting of the Holy Spirit
the Holy Spirit speaks to us through the
Word of God the Holy Spirit will speak
to us through our conscience when one
continually rejects truth that has been
revealed to him or her
and they continually do that and they
hardened their heart against the
promptings of the Holy Spirit that's
what leads to blasphemy against the Holy
Spirit or the unforgivable sin and the
reason it's unforgivable is if you've
rejected the Holy Spirit and the Holy
Spirit is needed to bring you to
repentance it's impossible to come to
repentance in order to be forgiven if
you've rejected the Holy Spirit so
that's why it's the son that can't be
forgiven it's because we we have no
desire to be forgiven
we've lost all interest in spiritual
things we've turned our back and walked
away from God now of course we are
grateful that God does forgive and we we
can never say oh I think this person
committed the unpardonable unpardonable
sin they've gone too far only God knows
the heart of a person but it is
important for us to recognize that we
want to be sensitive to the promptings
and the leading of the Holy Spirit does
that help Janice doesn't make sense
so when Paul's trying to solve is that
when he went to like to their to their
evil spirit to know which person was
that that would be like the blaspheme
against the Holy Spirit yes you're
referring to King Saul in the Old
Testament who had rejected the Holy
Spirit and the Holy Spirit had left him
and then in desperation because he is so
worried about a war that was to take
place he went and went to the Witch of
Endor
and actually devilled in the occult or
spiritualism and he died the next day so
yes he had committed the sin against the
Holy Spirit he had hardened his heart
and there was nothing that God could do
for him you know we do have a book that
we'll be happy to send you and it's
talking about the the unpardonable sin
and that's what it's cold you can just
call and ask for the free book on the
unpardonable sin the number is 883 five
six seven four seven that is our
resource phone line and ask for the book
on the unpardonable sin or the sin
against the Holy Spirit and we'll be
happy to send that to you next caller
that we have is a Wilma Wilma listening
from California Wilma welcome to the
program hey welcome thank you for
calling
yeah I'm just calling because I'm just
wondering about this one art like in
Revelation 1808
like the plagues will come in one day
what is that and also in the 10th 1810
if there's also one R and in the 17th it
says one R and there's also in 19th it's
one R okay all right very good
good question now just to give the
context of what we're talking about
we're talking about the place so that
come in the last days against those who
are the enemies of God's people
those were opposed to truth this happens
just before Jesus comes and it says in
verse 8 revelation 18 8 therefore her
plagues and it's talking about Babel and
Babylon is this symbolic name given to
those who are opposed to God's truth and
opposed to God's people in the last days
it says therefore plagues will come in
one day now there are seven plagues and
in Bible prophecy a day typically equals
a year so from this verse a number of
scholars have reached the conclusion
that the seven last plagues will
probably fall within the space of a year
and then just a little bit further one
of the plagues is a specific judgment
that comes upon Babylon itself so there
are these plagues that come upon the
world but then there's even more of a
specific judgment that comes upon
Babylon and that's verse 10 it says
standing at a distance for fear of a
torment saying alas alas that great city
that mighty City for in one hour your
judgment has come now one hour in Bible
prophecy is about two weeks and the way
we reach that is this 24 hours in a day
they are 360 days in a biblical year so
you can calculate do the math it comes
to about two weeks so it appears that
the seven last plagues fall roughly
within a year and this final destruction
of Babylon happens in a fairly short
period of time of about two weeks the
final judgment that comes does that help
Wilma all right you're welcome thank you
for your call
and next hole of that we have is
jeremiah jeremiah listening from
Oklahoma Jeremiah welcome to the program
hi thank you yes
thanks for calling and I hope Christian
my question no no we don't and let me
explain in the Old Testament we have at
least four categories of law that we
find we find the Ten Commandment law
which defines what sin is and that of
course is applicable to every nation
every person and that's universal that's
the moral or the Ten Commandments we
also find in the Old Testament what we
call health laws and the health laws had
to do with God guiding Israel helping
them to be healthy and the principles of
those health laws for example clean and
unclean animals certain things that you
wanted to do in order to have hygiene
washing of your hands and food
preparation those are good principles
and yes today as they're still binding
God wants Christians to follow good
health principles and to follow those
health laws in addition to the health
laws we also had the ceremonial laws and
the ceremonial laws had to had a lot to
do with the sanctuary the sacrificial
system the Levitical priesthood and
certain cultural things that God wanted
Israel to do which would set them apart
from the pagan nations that surrounded
them and so those laws the principles I
think are still valuable to us today but
the actual application we don't
sacrifice lambs anymore we don't have a
Levitical priesthood anymore Jesus is a
high priest and they have any sanctuary
we we're not a single nation any longer
but God's people are made up from every
nation kindred tongue and people so many
of those ceremonial laws as well as the
civil laws that govern the nation of
Israel that came to an end when Jesus
died on the cross so there are these
ceremonial laws the civil laws which are
not applicable to Christians today but
the health laws and the moral law they
are
lickable to Christians today um and can
I go a little bit deeper into my
question sure uh what about the mixing
of fabrics that's not the second issue
yes that's a good point it falls into
that category and the reason for that is
God wanted Israel to be distinct from
the nation surrounding them the mixing
of fabrics was used by the pagans Anna
was used in particular by those who were
involved in pagan worship for example
the pagan priests they would mix
different types of fabric they would
also cut the corners of their beard and
God wanted to make a clear distinction
between his people and those nations
surrounding them and the cultures that
those nations had and that's why we find
certain regulations and some of them you
might wonder why does God not want us to
mix different fabrics well it had to do
specifically to set israel apart from
those nations around them also you know
not cutting the corners of your beard
that was something that was done also in
pagan worship and God said I don't want
you to have anything to do with that
sorry what was that would that count
tattoos yes that's right God says not
marking your flesh now that is a New
Testament principle too of course
there's gonna be people saved who might
have a tattoo maybe they didn't know any
different but as Christians the Bible
tells us in the New Testament that our
bodies are the temple of the Holy Spirit
and we want to take care of our bodies
and the Bible does say we shouldn't be
putting markings on our flesh or tattoos
as some Bibles might have it so for a
Christian to knowingly go out and get a
tattoo that's probably not something
that would be pleasing to God if someone
you know becomes a Christian and they
have the tattoo there's not too much
they can do about it you know God does
forgive and we praise God for that so
thank you for your call Jeremiah friends
we have just a few seconds before we're
going to take our mid program break
we're not done we've still got lots of
Bible questions so look forward to
hearing from you if you have a Bible
question call us
after the break
stay tuned Bible answers live will
return shortly
[Music]
if you enjoy hearing solid biblical
answers on Bible answers live you can
have those same insights at your
fingertips through the amazing facts
prophecy Study Bible the updated
hardcover version is available at its
lowest price ever and includes the
complete set of amazing facts 27 study
guides plus a Bible numbers and symbols
charts and eight pages of colorful maps
this best-ever Bible gives you a
biblical cyclope dick index words of
Christ in red chronology of the Old
Testament
along with Doug Bachelors how to study
the Bible feature and much more call us
at AF bookstore to learn more about it
at one eight hundred five thirty eight
seventy two seventy five the amazing
facts prophecy Study Bible stands apart
from other Bibles giving you the same
solid answers you hear each week on
Bible answers live order your copy today
at AF bookstore calm or by calling 1-800
five three eight seventy two seventy
five
what if you could know the future
what would you do
[Music]
what would you change to see the future
you must understand the past Alexander
the Great becomes king when he's only 18
but he's a military prodigy a hundred
and fifty years in advance Cyrus had
been named wrong was violent they were
ruthless they were determined the Gospel
writers seek his death as a fulfillment
of salvation this intriguing documentary
hosted by Pastor Doug Batchelor explores
the most striking bible prophecies that
have been dramatically fulfilled
throughout history kingdoms in time get
your copy today available now on DVD
blu-ray or USB for more information
visit kingdoms in time.com you're
listening to Bible answers live where
every question answered provides a
clearer picture of God and his plan to
save you so what are you waiting for get
practical answers about the good book
for a better life today
if you have a question about the Bible
or living the Christian life call us now
at 800-831-6273 seven to nine seven that
is the phone line here to the studio the
other number 883 five six seven four
seven is our resource phone line and
we'll be giving you different resources
you can call that number and we'll be
happy to send it to you for free if you
have a Bible question again the number
800 four six three seven two nine seven
my name is John Ross pastor Doug is out
this evening but we are happy to take
your Bible questions we have a net who
is listening from Washington the net
welcome to the program yeah thanks for
waiting okay let me read it for those
who are listening on the radio it says
verse four first Timothy chapter four
verse 4 for every creature of God is
good and nothing to be refused if it is
received with Thanksgiving for it is
sanctified by the Word of God and prayer
and your question on now on okay I'm
just wondering okay all right well let's
let's talk about that for just a minute
do you think that's practical or healthy
that a person should eat anything that's
made any animal now let me ask you are
they some are they some things that are
not good to eat okay but I just
practically speaking are they poisonous
things that we shouldn't eat okay right
absolutely
well to answer this question I think
verse five is a big key it says for it
is sanctified by the Word of God and by
prayer now the word sanctified means
have been set apart or separated so are
there certain foods that in the Word of
God in the Bible have been separated
which God has said you can eat and are
there certain foods or certain animals
that God has said in the Bible you
should not eat new thing no you're right
the Bible does set apart certain animals
and it's called clean animals and
unclean animals and in the Old Testament
God was very clear that the unclean
animals they were mostly scavenging type
animals were not to be eaten but people
could eat the clean animals well that
same principle is still applied in the
New Testament or one of the requirements
of New Testament believers was that they
weren't to eat blood and that came from
the Levitical regulations about clean
monthly animals so here the situation
that Paul is addressing when he's
writing this to Timothy is there were
certain Christians in the church who
were telling other Christians that on
certain times of the year or certain
days of the year they were not allowed
to eat certain things now what it is
that they said you weren't allowed to
eat were things that the Bible said you
could eat and that's why Paul says every
creature of God is good if it is
sanctified by the word so those things
that have been sanctified or set apart
by the Word of God those are acceptable
you can eat them there were people that
were trying to tell Christians not to
eat those things and that's what Paul
was addressing oh so he's talking about
like the Book of Leviticus - yes and the
principle there is is pretty simple if
if the animal has a cloven hoof like a
sheep or a cow and it chews the cud that
is clean you can eat that an animal that
doesn't have a cloven hoof or that
doesn't chew the cud those are unclean
animals and we shouldn't be eating that
of course reptiles and those type of
things they oles unclean you know we do
have a book that talks about that and
we'll be happy to send this to you it's
actually one of our study guides and
it's called God's free health plan and
we'll be happy to send this to anyone
who wants to learn more the number to
call for that is eight hundred eight
three five six seven four seven and you
can just ask for the amazing fact study
guide it's called God's free health plan
our next caller that we have is Matthew
listening in Toronto Canada Matthew
welcome to the program hi pastor hi
thanks a coal furnace my question this
even is why did God kiss Adam and Eve in
a perfect garden but at the same time he
gave them two trees to choose from okay
we're gonna lean in the garden every
time okay now you know God has made us
just like he may be angels all
intelligent beings with freedom of
choice and the reason for that is love
that does not provide freedom is not
true love so God being a God of love
gave Adam and Eve freedom and that
freedom allowed them to choose whether
they would be loyal to God or whether
they choose not to be loyal to God now
if God only had the Tree of Life in the
garden but he didn't allow the tree of
the knowledge of good and evil to be in
the garden well then God would have
removed Adam and Eve's ability to choose
God to choose to love God because they
didn't have another choice so when God
gave both trees or put both trees in the
garden and God said to Adam and Eve
don't eat of this tree God was giving
them a test that God is giving them the
opportunity to choose who they gain to
be loyal to
now of course unfortunately you know
that Adam he chose to disobey God and
they showed loyalty rather to the devil
then to God but God in His mercy did not
reject them he provided a plan
Redemption so that we have hope so that
we can be saved had Adam and Eve been
faithful to God and not given in to the
devil's temptations would have stayed
away from the tree of the knowledge of
good and evil I imagine at some point
that tree would have been removed
because they would have had proved their
faithfulness to God and there was no
need for that any longer but you know
that would have been ideal but you know
what happened and Adam and Eve sinned
and of course we are where we are today
but we do have hope and that hope is in
Jesus so they did God spoke to them and
told him God you know we don't know how
long Adam and Eve were in the garden
before they ate of the tree of the
knowledge of good and evil but God told
them stay away from the tree he must
have told him that there was this
rebellious angel that was trying to get
their loyalty and that's why the devil
probably does guys himself as a talking
snake to try and deceive and he did he
deceived Eve and he gave the fruit to
Adam so God did warn them God gave them
the information that they needed and yet
they chose to disobey and they regretted
it afterwards no doubt about it
and you know they wish they hadn't done
that so that the possibility the
possibility lies in that because it was
a fall and being the possibility that
they could have sinned them well you
know God God has given every creature
you and I each of us have the freedom of
choice we can choose to obey God or we
could choose to disobey God allows us to
make that choice and we're grateful that
God doesn't just give us one chance
otherwise we'd all be in trouble but God
is merciful and he forgives us even when
we make mistakes and that's what he did
for Adam and Eve when they sinned God
was merciful and he planned a way of
salvation and the plan of redemption
that came into effect so we can praise
God for the freedom and thank him for
the freedom that we do have well thank
you Matthew for your call we're going to
go to our next caller here before we run
out of time let's see we've got
Olivia listening from Washington Olivia
welcome to the program hi and your your
question tonight like David Goliath and
tell other people to tell certain people
all right good question Olivia now in
the commandment it tells us that we
should not kill is the King James but if
you look up the word it means murder so
there is a difference between killing
and murder marie's when somebody
purposely takes innocent life that would
be considered murder but in the case of
David and Goliath here you have an enemy
that he's threatening to destroy God's
people God comes to the defense of the
children of Israel and God works in a
dramatic miraculous way in enabling
David to kill the judge the giant of
course David he threw the stone but
really it was God that destroyed the
Giant or brought the giant down to his
knees and he died so God was very much
involved in that so there is a
difference between murder and killing
sometimes unfortunately somebody might
be involved in an accident and
accidentally hurt someone or even killed
him well we don't consider them a
murderer because they didn't want to do
that
it wasn't purposeful the taking of
innocent life is murder but sometimes
God had directed individuals to act do
an act of judgment to destroy for the
purpose of protecting and delivering his
own people and that's the case with
David and Goliath but good question
Olivia we got Sherri listening from
Montana
sherry welcome to the program Oh welcome
I was wondering if you could explain the
hundred and forty-four thousand yes no I
see okay good question
Revelation chapter 7 talks about the
hundred and forty-four thousand it talks
about twelve thousand from each of the
tribes of Israel the order in which
that's listed in Revelation chapter
seven is unique the way the tribes are
listed twelve thousand from each of the
tribes and if you look up the meaning of
the names of the tribes that are listed
it gives you a description of the
experience that God's people will go
through in the last days now I don't
have time beginning to all of the
details of that but really the hundred
and forty-four thousand represent God's
people in the last days who have the
seal of God and who do a special work of
taking the gospel to the world they sort
of God's last-day apostles in taking the
gospel to the world sort of the loud cry
are they only going to be 144,000 people
that are saved when Jesus comes I don't
think so because Revelation chapter 7
also talks about a great multitude of
people who are saved from every nation
kindred tongue so 144,000 represent
God's last-day
evangelist so to speak those who are
taking the gospel to every nation
kindred tongue and people
I remember in Revelation it's a symbolic
book we're not only talking about Jews
making up 144,000 the Jews or Israel in
Revelation represents God's people and
if you believe in Christ then you're
Abraham's seed heirs according to the
promise does that make sense sherry yes
it does you helped me a lot I highly
appreciate it all right I used to think
that there was only gonna be a hundred
and forty-four thousand standing on the
earth so you've clarified that greatly
all right you're welcome we do have a
book called
who are 144,000 and we're getting to the
subject in more detail and sherry will
be happy to send it to you the number to
call is 883 five six seven four seven
you can ask for the book called who at
144,000 next caller that we have is
Michael listening from looks like
Virginia Michael welcome to the program
thank you hi and your question this
evening
my Guzman is indeed Satan's probation in
when did Satan's probation end the Bible
does not specifically say but it would
appear that when he was cast out of
heaven that you know there was no hope
of him ever returning or passing the
point of repentance and Jesus said that
he saw Satan falling as lightning from
heaven so I would I would assume that
what it would have occurred before the
earth was created alright well hopefully
that helps Michael thank you for your
question alright makes whole of the
behalf looks like we got Lorinda
listening from Washington Lorinda
welcome to the program thank you my
question is if God accept cremation does
God accept cremation you're talking
about in the resurrection can he
resurrect people who are cremated yeah
yeah yes the answer is yes absolutely in
the Bible typically of the form of
taking care of the Dead is burial and we
all the way back to Abraham you have
examples of God's people bearing of
their loved ones their family members
but there were also many other believers
who were put to death
there were many believers in the Dark
Ages who were burned at the stake and
they going to be resurrected when Jesus
comes there were those who were lost at
sea
they going to be resurrected when Jesus
comes so you know really what cremation
is it's just speeding up the process if
somebody is buried it might take a
little longer for decomposition to occur
cremation speeds it up so is there
anything wrong in a person being
cremated no can God still resurrect
someone who's cremated absolutely thank
you very much all right you're welcome
thanks for calling next hole of the
behalf is Tara listening from Fort
Lauderdale in Florida Tara often to the
program
hello hi hi possum wedding my question
is before Jesus died on the cross and
saved us from all our sins was Abraham
Moses and the rest of them in Hell
waiting for him no um you know before
Jesus died on the cross those living in
the Old Testament they looked forward to
the coming of the Messiah the coming of
Christ who would die for their sins and
as an as an example of their faith as a
demonstration of their faith they would
offer a sacrifice and in the Old
Testament we have many examples of
people that were offering sacrifices and
that goes all the way back to Cain and
Abel right after Adam and Eve was sent
out of the Garden of Eden and they had
sons so the sacrificial or the
sacrificing of a lamb was way back even
in Old Testament times before Abraham
sacrifices continued right up till the
time of Jesus and it was a symbol of
Christ but people were saved before
Christ's death by believing in a coming
Redeemer in the New Testament we're
saved by looking back to the fact that
Jesus did die for essence and that we
are forgiven so people before the cross
and after the cross they were all saved
the same way everyone is saved by the
sacrifice of Jesus all right thanks for
calling - appreciate your call tonight
we could JC listening in Atlanta Georgia
JC welcome to the program can you
explain that yes I think we can you know
God's plan is for life and the Bible
says God is not willing that any should
perish but that all should come to
repentance the reason we have sickness
and suffering and death in the world
today is because of sin and we're
bearing the consequences of sin and
unfortunately living in a sinful world
these things happen where innocent
people might get sick might even die so
it's not God that brings this on God
will allow certain things to happen but
at the end of the day God is wanting to
create a new heavens and a new earth
wherein dwells righteousness where
there's no sorrow no suffering but why
has Jesus not come yet and created that
new world well the Bible says God is
long-suffering not willing that any
should perish but the day of the Lord
will come so why is Jesus not come yet
because he wants to give as much time as
possible to try and save people but the
time will come when Jesus says enough is
enough there's enough pain enough sorrow
enough suffering I'm coming I'm gonna
make all things new
does that help JC yes alright thank you
for calling
we've got William listening in Kentucky
William welcome to the program hey HAP
Esther hi thanks for calling my past now
yeah
my question was concerning baptism okay
especially like the baptism of young
people have a have a young son and you
know the way this world's gone I just
I'm just doing a little bit fouled up
because you know like the age of
accountability and if he were to and it
was to come upon his heart you know I
would be all about it but what about the
people who take it upon themselves you
know that to baptize children not
knowing if they fully committed or
understand what they're doing okay well
I think first of all there's been a
misunderstanding of what baptism is
there's a lot of traditions that have
kind of crept in over the years in
Christianity most of it came from a
misunderstanding what baptism means
during the Dark Ages a belief became
very prominent in the established church
that if you were not baptized there was
no way that you could be saved well in
those days there was a high rate of
death amongst children and babies and so
people started baptizing their children
and even baptizing babies thinking that
if they weren't baptized they weren't
able to be saved but baptism is really a
public commitment that a person makes to
Jesus they need to be old enough to
understand what they are doing if they
don't understand what they are doing how
can they make that public commitment or
that decision for Christ
so the baptism needs to take place when
a young person is old enough to know
right from wrong
where the Holy Spirit is speaking to
their hearts you know with each child
it's a little different but usually it's
somewhere around the age of 12 to 14
maybe even a little early at 10 it's
within that timeframe some of the things
that I look for if I'm gonna be
baptizing a young person is I want them
to understand what it is they're doing
understand the importance of baptism you
want them to have a personal
relationship with Jesus through prayer
and through the reading of His Word and
they need to be able to make that that
commitment saying I I asked Jesus to
forgive me for my sins and I commit my
life to Him those are some of the
important things that they need to be
able to make those decisions and then
there's some other foundational Bible
truths that he's also important for them
to understand yes exactly I agree with
you 100 cents on people struggling today
you know after they made the commitment
and then they fall back upon you know if
they've let the Lord down and then
what's going to happen to them you know
well you know the good news is that God
does forgive and we have many examples
of people who have already made that
commitment and yet they have sinned how
they come back to God they are forgiven
and in the case of baptism I know of
young people who made the decision to be
baptized but as time went on maybe they
wandered away from that commitment and
even walked away from God but that
baptism was always there and it the Holy
Spirit spoke to their hearts and they
came back so you know if a person is
ready to make that decision to be
baptized I would encourage them be
baptized keep trusting in Jesus if you
wonder away don't give up God doesn't
give up on us we need to go back and
he'll forgive us okay thank you very
much pastor all right thank you for your
call William we appreciate that next
caller that we have is Robert listening
from Washington Robert welcome to the
program hello pastor Ross hi thanks for
calling
I got I got squeezed in huh yes we got
you in my question is regarding
Galatians 5 18 of them it says if we're
living by the spirit
we shouldn't obey the law all right well
let me read it here it's Galatians 5 18
it says but if you are led by the spirit
you are not under the law now let me
explain what he's talking about
the law that Paul is referring to here
in Galatians is not the Ten Commandment
law because if you look on in verse 19
he talks about the works of the flesh
which are adultery fornication
uncleanness hatred sorcery jealousy
outbursts of Wrath well or where does
the Bible talk about adultery Benison
well it's part of the Ten Commandment
law the law that Paul's referring to
were the ceremonial laws that the Jewish
Christians were telling the Gentile
Christians to obey for example the Rite
of circumcision the Jewish believers how
Christians would tell the Gentile
Christians are you have to be
circumcised or you can't be saved the
pulse is no no that law came to an end
when Jesus died on the cross but he's
not talking about the Ten Commandment
law because the Ten Commandment law
defines what sin is and so yes of course
God wants Christians to to keep the Ten
Commandments does that help
Robert yes yes thank you very much all
right you're welcome thanks for your
call I mixed call to behavior just a few
moments we got polar you know higher
polar welcome to the program hi thank
you
hi thanks for calling yeah my question
was so I am an aspiring position and
I've been like reading about
vaccinations I'm not originally from the
US and I hear different opinions all the
time like some coming from Christians
and not and I the specific vaccine in
question was I guess MMR because the
cells come from aborted beat ourselves
but for me I was just looking for
practical biblical principles to how a
kid navigate you know that field of
vaccinations and without boil avoiding
extreme okay good
question you know I think there is good
science behind certain vaccines and we
know that it's helps to prevent disease
and as a Christian I don't think we
should be opposed to preventing disease
but at the same line if a vaccine
requires the death of an unborn child
well then obviously as Christians we
would have some concerns because you
know that would be against what the
Bible says but just in general vaccines
I I don't think any Christians would
have a problem with that all sincere
Christian God wants us to make wise
choices he wants us to be healthy and if
that involves the vaccine I there's no
conflict from a Christian perspective as
to whether or not to get that now you
know in each situation might be a little
different and each person's you know
physical ability might be different and
that's where we need to be laid
individually but just in general the
idea of a vaccine that's not in any way
against any of the teachings of the
Bible
thank you for your call Paul are we just
looking at the time and friends probably
we don't have enough time to take
another call for this evening but if we
didn't get to your call
we hope you won't give up call us back
next Sunday evening are we gonna have
another program a Bible answers live I
believe pastor Doug will be joining us
next week if you have more questions or
would like to learn more about what the
Bible says go to the amazing facts
website just amazing facts dot o-r-g or
dot-com and there you'll find the free
online bible school and you can sign up
it goes through all 27 lessons covering
a wide variety of subjects I think
you'll be richly blessed if you take
time to go through the amazing facts
study guide series and again thank you
for being a part of our program if you'd
like to help support amazing facts thank
you too god bless
thank you for listening to today's
broadcast
we hope you understand your Bible even
better than before Bible answers live is
produced by amazing facts International
a faith-based ministry located in
Granite Bay California if you enjoy
hearing solid biblical answers on Bible
answers live you can have those same
insights at your fingertips through the
amazing facts prophecy Study Bible the
updated hardcover version is available
at its lowest price ever and includes
the complete set of amazing facts 27
study guides plus a Bible numbers and
symbols charts and eight pages of
colorful maps this best-ever Bible gives
you a biblical cyclope dick index words
of Christ in red chronology of the Old
Testament
along with Doug Bachelors how to study
the Bible feature and much more call us
at AF bookstore to learn more about it
at one eight hundred five thirty eight
seventy two seventy five the amazing
facts prophecy Study Bible stands apart
from other Bibles giving you the same
solid answers you hear each week on
Bible answers live order your copy today
at AF bookstore com or by calling 1-800
five three eight seventy two seventy
five
what if you could know the future what
would you do what would you change to
see the future you must understand the
past Alexander the Great becomes king
when he's only 18 but he's a military
prodigy a hundred and fifty years in
advance Cyrus had been named Rahm was
violent they were ruthless they were
determined the Gospel writers seek his
death as a fulfillment of salvation this
intriguing documentary hosted by pastor
Doug Batchelor explores the most
striking bible prophecies that have been
dramatically fulfilled throughout
history kingdoms in time get your copy
today available now on DVD blu-ray or
USB for more information visit kingdoms
in time.com for life-changing christian
resources this @af bookstore calm
if you'd like to enhance your study of
God's Word
visit our website at www.flcfs.org ette
the most out of God's word to take
advantage of the offers you've heard on
this broadcast call us at